Цей пам'ятник "Солдат і моряк" заввишки 40 метрів
нависає над Севастополем, нагадуючи про роль міста
в радянській та російській військовій історії.
Коли Росія анексувала український Крим 4 роки тому,
навіть найближчі союзники Росії не визнали цього кроку.
Втім, для деяких місцевих жителів все це не має значення.
Видихнули спокійно, бо ми повернулися на свою батьківщину.
У мене не було батьківщини, якою б я пишалася.
Коли були Олімпійські ігри, я вболівала за Росію.
Коли потрібно було дитині читати казки, я читала
російські казки, я розповідала про російських царів, бо я це знаю.
Захід відреагував економічними санкціями, які чинні й нині.
Міжнародні компанії залишили півострів - McDonalds став "Мирбургер".
І що більш критично: Крим залишили багато банків.
Тут не приймаються міжнародні картки і неможливо зняти готівку.
Так само і з іноземними мобільними телефонами:
приїзд у Крим означає втрату сигналу.
Але окрім санкцій, що ще змінилося для людей у Севастополі?
Нелегко відповісти на це запитання.
Висловлюючи сумніви щодо легітимності російського контролю над півостровом,
можна потрапити за ґрати на термін до п'яти років.
Мені стало простіше жити.
Як жила, так і живу. Ніщо особливо не змінилося.
Найбільше, що впадає в око, - це президентські вибори.
На кожному кроці плакати нагадують людям про їхній обов'язок проголосувати.
Лише от виповнилось 18 років.
З великими емоціями йду на вибори.
Я сподіваюся, що наша молодь зробить правильний вибір.
На мою думку, це Володимир Володимирович Путін.
У цій чудовій країні немає сенсу ходити на вибори.
Навіть російських космонавтів залучили до виборчої агітації.
Одна з небагатьох меншин, яка, найімовірніше,
не слідуватиме цьому заклику, - кримські татари.
У 40-х роках минулого століття їх переслідувала радянська влада
й депортувала в Середню Азію.
Лише після повалення комунізму татарам було дозволено повернутися додому.
Чотири роки тому російська влада заборонила "Меджліс" -
представницький орган кримських татар, -
і закрила татарськомовний телеканал.
Утім, цей конфлікт також стосується і землі.
Замість фінансової компенсації за депортацію
цій татарській родині, як і багатьом іншим,
за української влади давали землю для будівництва житла.
Нині ж, стверджують татари, Росія відмовляє їм у цьому.
Погрожують нам, що знесуть, прийдуть бульдозери і знесуть наші будинки.
Люди у відчаї. Багато хто боїться, що залишиться без житла.
Ми влаштовували голодування, але це в жодному ЗМІ не показують.
Якщо хоч невеликий мітинг чи плакат – одразу арешт на 10 діб.
Організатор наших акцій зараз під арештом.
Ввечері в центрі Севастополя - море прапорів та бар'єрів безпеки.
Чекають на появу Володимира Путіна.
Завдяки вашому рішенню Севастополь і Крим
повернулися у свій рідний дім – дім нашої спільної батьківщини –
нашої матінки-Росії.
Володимир Путін сподівається, що пам'яті про ці події достатньо,
щоб люди прийшли на виборчі дільниці,
незважаючи на те, що багато хто сприймає ці вибори
як вже вирішену справу.